[Music]
today i'm stuck between two
countries i have a permanent work contract
from the beginning of march 2021
with the university of
applied sciences of western norway when
patatras
the news comes norway closes its
borders we have an apartment  that
we had to find in an emergency
to find accommodation here in brussels and we
have we had already rented an
apartment in bergen to
settle there permanently where
we find ourselves with two accommodations
but nowhere I started to
work the  March 1st are virtual
given that it is impossible for
me to go to Norway I am French I
live in Brussels
I am married to a Belgian citizen
we want to live in Norway Europe
the Schengen area means living beyond
the  borders for us the opening of
borders is part of the identity
of European citizens and we
hope that what we all
experienced last year does not happen
again and that  solutions are put
in place to sustain the opening
of borders
[Music]